I'm African I'm African I'm African I'm
African I'm African I'm African I am
African hi what's up guys what's
everyone's name where you from I'll
start I'm sadik from Ghana born and
raised when did you move oh um 2013
August 24th was actually my tenure at
anniversary so I've been here for 10
years hi everyone my name is debah um I
was born in lagas
Nigeria and yeah she never said when she
came to the US and I just felt like
she's been here her whole life uh my
name is Blessing I was born in poot um
and I moved to America I think I was
like five I've lived in Los Angeles ever
since okay hi my name is Inda I'm well
my dad is from Central African Republic
I was born and raised there but my mom
is from Ivory Coast so it's like I was
raised in both places and I moved to the
United States when I was 8 years old she
said she was born and raised in two
countries I feel like if you're the fake
that's a good strategy to use it's going
to be harder to quiz someone from two
countries what place did you like better
I liked every Coast no shade to my dad
it's just that like The Vibes are more
beaches my family yeah
West my name is Elizabeth I was born and
raised in abela State
Nigeria hi everyone my name is Sheil I'm
Kenyan born and raised Nairobi Kenya I
moved here last year okay hi guys my
name is Sam but I go by the name big Sam
cuz you know every we do it big we do it
big
okay I was born in Zambia born and
raised in Zambia then I came here like
four five years ago so you know trying
to get used to things still but yeah
that's that okay I already forgot
everyone's name
but
[Music]
the accent and speaking Yorba maybe she
was
overcompensating she was just too
quiet just the way that I sound I think
my accent is more towards like an
American sounding accent
I have a question when we're here we
have to speak like Americans sometimes
and like Africans sometimes so what's
like your American accent and what's
your African accent so my African accent
comes more when I'm speaking to family
and other people from Africa like right
now I feel like I'm speaking to Africans
so it's coming out but I I'm also
interacting and I work with a lot of
white people so sometimes I have
to I was just like he's an actor he
could be be acting he could be lying you
these actors they know how to play it
off every time I try to like do American
accent I can start like I be like oh y y
y and then before I know it I will start
speaking rubbish okay and that African
accent will always come out is it I'll
yell sometime accidentally I'll just be
like for me it's only when I'm
frustrated for me it's like with my
family for sure like right now I'm
talking but like I speak French so it's
not so I'm not gonna like talk like like
it's not like the Nigerian accent you
know there English in there it's more
like a French accent and you can kind of
hear it when I talk but you like it's
like it's back there know what I mean
even though she was French speaking that
would have been a bit more obvious but I
could only hear America in her accent
also I agree with what you said with
frustration when you're in emotional
situations you don't really think before
you talk you just speak what about you
Sam so basically mine I I could never F
an American accent to save my life even
when I even when I think I'm trying to
fake it it just never works out cuz my
friends are like so what do you think
you did
there but you're also not from West
Africa I feel like West Africa like our
English is I'm from Zambia Zambia is
like sou so I have like the typical
African accent like the wakanda
accent yeah because like now now I've
accepted it is what it is let's just you
know quate what it is I think me too cuz
I'm you know the accent they make black
Americans speak when they're trying to
be African you're Nigerian right Rec
State and Capal you said what states and
capital all of the states and capital
just
tryy why don't you restate the states
and
capital do it because I grew up in
America I can't even do that for the 50
states a good point what's like an
expression in your country that people
say like as a like whenever they're like
let's say they're yeah
shock more like hi how about you
[Music]
[Applause]
yay I do want to say though before the
time run out and I'm I'm I'm so sorry
blessing I'm going to come for you come
for me and I feel I genuinely feel like
if you're a Nigerian there's no way you
cannot recite the state and capital if
you grew up in Nigeria like they beat us
5 years and then I came to the states I
didn't I didn't even go to yeah I didn't
even start scho in Nigeria like I start
school and you're 5 years old yeah we
moved we moved not remember my dad was a
lecturer moved to Los Angeles how are
you Nigerian and you cannot
do because they literally beat us to
learn that Nigerians when you were five
do you remember who the president was
when you were young when I was five I
think it was a b oner she's oh no she's
right9 9 to 201 all right guys you all
requested this video don't forget to
like this video so you can get more
episode and leave your comment down
below and make sure you subscribe to
Jubilee like her outfit just just I just
thought she was American she looked she
looked
American maybe blessing is not lying cuz
his attitude his Aura his energy was
giving Nigerian Sam when I see him with
the tennis everything no way with that
hair no way you're not African bro
okay it is a
tie between blessing and Inda each of
you are going to get 40 seconds to State
your case
uh so I didn't want to say this because
it's just so personal to me I was
debating talking about it on camera to
come to the US I had to like there was a
war in my
country in Central African Republic
wongi it's still going on now and we had
to leave because I had family members
that like you know just we lost them
through the war and uh so we had to find
Refugee or asylum in the United
States um sorry that's okay that's okay
are you okay Inda I'm okay I'm okay okay
before I begin I just want to say I'm
sorry about all that my parents do a lot
of work in central Africa Republic they
do missions so very aware of the
situation and sorry to hear about that
but to you specifically person who body
you know the enter Legos I shouldn't be
expected to be a Legos boy that's it so
yeah like I said I came ATO 5 my dad is
a lecturer so he got an opportunity to
come to United States and teach so yeah
all all my upbringing is American I am
super American but deep down I'm a
boy atat um yeah that's it I'm a
boyat you know I even call my blood you
can't see it but obviously it's a very
hard position to be in because I think
everybody here is African already so
it's very
hard Inda told a very personal story and
it would be a bit insensitive to bring
something that has happened to lots of
people and use it as your own
story it's something very sensitive to
you know call out didn't think what she
was talking about was a lie but I just
thought she didn't really go through
that and she began to cry but I didn't
see a single teer I had a genuine
reaction like oh I'm so sorry to hear
that cuz I know a lot of War goes on in
Africa but at the same time it was Inda
versus blessing if it was maybe Inda
versus Sam of course you know where I
will
pick you guys I cried for
you
I honestly was kind of shocked because
that would be really like sick of an
individual to just make that up but I'm
glad I got to speak about it and
hopefully it brings attention to the
issues that are going on if everyone
feels confident that you already caught
the mole you can end the game now please
raise your hand if you want to continue
playing
continue all right okay I'm I'm going to
go Sam I'm coming for you do not go see
first of all first of all the energy was
just giving oh my God don't catch me
first of a second of a wait calm down
bro see I noticed something about
African men when they move here they
their their fashion sense will be
different your fashion is giving me um
you're not I swear you look good I was
like first of all this shirt is great
okay this is spb like I've got this from
Target okay
G me African no no no he's giving me
some an American that is like in Senior
High SCH you're foret this he's a nerd
he's an actor wait this between the two
of you you guys conv me I'm feeling like
an African that was raised in Africa
okay you don't dress like that but then
I I'm trying not to judge you cuz you're
from Zambia and I'm not going to lie I'm
not extremist honestly even in Kenya
guys dress like this I think you
first moved from Ghana to the states I
dress similar to you West African when
did you come here when did you come here
2018 so so you went to what school like
did you go to high school here college
or what high I did so been primary
school high school I did everything back
in my country in Zambia what was the
name of your teacher in Prim I had so
many teachers on what so you moved here
for college you moved here for College
college 2018 on what kind of Visa
student visa what what other visa do you
what's the called what's the C you
should F1
F1 if you ask me that question I would
have feel cuz I didn't come on St did
you come did you come on what did you
come I come here cuz my grandparents
have been living here so they f for my
dad me they f for us like so we just
come here as green carder what's the
hardest part about living here as an
African one thing that I found a little
weird but not hard was the fact that
Americans enjoy cold food like you know
food just left on the table Yeah like
cold pizza or like just leave there I
like my food hot you know if I feel like
most Africans you know they eat their
food straight from the port first of all
when I first F got here and you people
were kissing in public that
was 2015 2015 2018 2018 uh last year
2022 2013 you came just last year yeah
really so they weren't here for like the
hard part cuz when you guys came like
Africa was already kind of cool yeah way
back when we were
here I don't think I would have done
High African booty scratch you guys you
guys are walking to school riding on
elephant to school
you have to play along I feel like I'm
an outsider twice because I came here
and like in my school there's a lot of
black students so I'm like ah there's
black people like me but once I say I'm
African it's like I'm not even like the
other black people you know I'm
separated from them so since I lived
here for so long it was um like the
cultural differences like my parents
didn't let me do anything right like
couldn't couldn't go to like parties
couldn't spend the night at friend's
house even like at a certain point like
Jordan things like that my dad didn't
want me to come like one of those yoyoy
guys so like they didn't want me doing
any
of yeah so like certain things like he
would just not let us even wear cuz yeah
what it would like represent so I think
for me that was like the hardest thing
not being able to like fully integrate
and going to school and still kind of
being an outsider but I'm like but I've
been here like I'm basically
African-American I wanted to add one
small thing also like pronunciations
words when I first came there certain
times that people yeah you start talking
and people stop paying attention to you
just cuz they don't understand what
you're saying and then that makes you a
little bit more timid you know like I
can't even order from drivethru okay
come to the front I I'm not coming to
the front you're going to hear what I'm
saying two order bger two party they
wanted to kill me okay okay I feel like
for me it was making friends we had I
feel like Americans are very open like
you meet them they'll tell you about
their
div every single thing that has happened
in their life and then H they give you
the number and your mind thinking oh our
friends were cool this is it like we're
locked in this is for Life tomorrow they
don't pick up your phone call M that's
so
true and they even walk
past he had the African attire and I
just felt like that was too
obvious every time I look at that table
and I need to vote I just see you
okay Elizabeth she started like pressing
Sam you can see he was getting nervous
like he started like fumbling in his
answers I was like yes it's like an
Auntie is actually peppering him now
like he doesn't know what to
do we have another
tiebreaker oh between Sam and sadik I
will give the rest of the group a minute
to deliberate on who you want to vote
off vote
wisely mind your business okay don't
believe
himash I don't believe he say that he
say that I would never never compare
to I know what he's saying he's I feel
like you're coming from the perspective
of your Canan andbody can defend you the
way weend each other but she doesn't
agree so but it's two against one so all
right that was hard I hope I don't cry
after this
okay West Africans always ring election
I'm
sorry I
tried just the agenda I saw
it actually thought I was out actually
thought I was out that was so snaky I so
betrayed because like I'm the most
African African please raise your hand
if you would like to continue playing
the game continue I want to continue I
feel like we should so to you guys it's
three against one the game is
done if the lights turn green you caught
the mole and you win if the lights turn
red you didn't catch them they're still
in the game and you lose three two
one I swe I'm going to kill one of you
guys what the hell why is it one of us
no it's not her there's something she
said can the mole please step forward
and reveal
themselves 3 2
1 I knew it I knew it
knew was way too
impressive was way too impressive I'm
sorry I'm sorry please forgive me I knew
that but I'm still a n guy true and true
almost everything today I said was true
the only difference is that I was
actually born here and then I went back
for like 2 years and then I came back to
State
St feel
B no hard feelings for being eliminated
it's the game I can't really do anything
about that I just know that it'll cause
some reflection Maybe maybe from the
people and you know not to assume or to
just open your heart I got voted out
because there was an agenda an agenda to
keep the West Africans in but she was
like well I'm going to save my little
brother from Nigeria and then now she
finds out that he was the one that was
actually lying so look at you dear
Sam I'm so sorry bro I swear to God see
I love you Sam okay genuinely and I
apologize my dear inder I felt bad that
even though you cried and you were being
vulnerable at that time I still voted
you out I'm so sorry I kind of felt that
I was going to win this one to be fair
they're all really cool uh whenever I'm
around like other Africans especially
West Africans you always click love all
you guys when you're watching this I
didn't mean to lie but I had to do it
for the bag I had to do it for the bag R
NAA wow wow
wow